[Music]
hey george campbell here co-host of the
ramsay show and we are back with another
installment of the best of the ramsay
show everybody makes financial mistakes
but some are crazier than others and
this episode features some of the
craziest financial mistakes our callers
have made check it out
jack is in california hi jack welcome to
the ramsey show
hey dave how's it going better than i
deserve how can we help
um so i wanted some some advice on on my
current situation
um i started binge watching your show
about three weeks ago and
decided okay i'm gonna because i want to
buy a house soon so i paid off all my
credit cards um
but the problem i'm having right now is
i have a car that's
i spent way too much on last year and i
bought it brand new because i drive
about 100 mile round trip um
so i spent 52 000 on my car um
and it's about a 836 dollar payment um
and i was thinking okay i'm just going
to go ahead and pay this off
um because the value has already
decreased to like 38 000 when i looked
it up on kelly blue book
so what i wanted advice on was i have
about twenty thousand dollars in my
savings good and
i put my 401k on on hold just like good
um because i have i had about 15 going
in there um i'm 25 years old i got 40k
in there which i want to use for a house
um this year i'll make between 120 and
150. excellent okay so and you the
balance on the car is what
the balance on the car is about 47 000
because i just bought it in september of
last year gotcha so you throw 20 at it
and that leaves us with 27 and you make
100 and some change and you pay it off
in a year right
yeah so that's what my my question was
because i was thinking of keeping like
ten thousand dollars in my savings no
okay
you're broke man
800
yeah no it's ridiculous yeah it's
horrible
i'd be i'd be freaking out
yeah and i i realized uh you know
watching your show and then i started
paying off my credit card and i was like
you know what if i if i want to buy a
house i'm going to have a mortgage
payment and an 800 car payment now
you're not doing realistic
i'll come to california and box your
ears you're not doing that
no you you no you you're too smart to do
that let me tell you where you're
struggling okay
you've learned all of this information
and implemented all of this in a very
short period of time your intellect went
way ahead and left your emotions behind
right you know what i'm saying like you
understood this intellectually and you
went like ding ding ding ding ding and
you start doing it and then you're kind
of like getting a little bit of
emotional whiplash because this has all
happened in a relatively short period of
time agreed
yeah and and you know what watching your
show helps me out so much because a lot
of this stuff is the stuff that my my
parents are very frugal um and they
taught me all this stuff and they were
freaking out when you bought this 52 000
car yeah but they let they let me make
my mistakes well yeah
you're a grown man and that you know
stupid's not illegal and you explained
it to them in a good way why you needed
this one too yeah 100 miles a week which
means i'm going to destroy the value
faster
that was that was me justifying it in my
head yeah but i knew i heard you did
when i was doing it yeah i heard you but
you made me realize uh how stupid it is
when i started watching your show i
think i think you're smart and i think
you're going to turn this around it's
just the re the reason you're saying but
but
i'm gonna keep the ten thousand dollars
is is not because you intellectually
don't see how this is all gonna pan out
it's because you've done it all in a
very short period of time and you went
from way over here in the land of stupid
to
rushing over into the land of the wise
and you got a little whiplash doing it
emotionally it takes your emotions a
little time to catch up so give yourself
permission to go this feels weird but
i'm gonna do it anyway
and you feel exposed when you get down
to that one thousand dollars and i think
that's the point right yeah we want you
running well and we want all that money
throwing at this stupid car to get rid
of this debt
but when somebody binge watches dave
they realize oh gosh i'm not safe and
they immediately want to get safe now
yeah and so it's i get that impulse i
gotta hang on to this and let me tell
you the other thing those of you out
there that are uh you know you've been
broke for
20 years living paycheck to paycheck and
you work through this stuff and you work
your butt off and you're gonna sell
intense for three years and then you're
debt-free and you don't have any
payments and then you start actually
getting some money and then you look up
and you go dead gum i have several
hundred thousand dollars and i have no
debt
there's a there's another thing that
happens is your emotions are still back
there when you were broke yeah and it
feels weird to be able to buy a ten
thousand dollar thing
and just write a check for it and it's
not a big deal
yeah mathematically intellectually but
your emotions are like back there when
you were broke right so you gotta heal
along the way too yeah i mean we spend
more on copier paper and coffee here
than i used to make
right in this building i mean okay i
have a thousand employees well i look
down at that number and i see your heart
stops numbers going through i'm like i'm
that little 28 year old guy that's back
there broke 30 years ago i'm like crap
yeah what a coffee you know it's like oh
it's a lot of coffee so you know the
last time i bought a new car when i was
an idiot was was
a long time ago
i went to we're looking at buying my
wife a new car and or a used car
new to her i thought
when did the prices go up and she was
like 25 years ago right but yeah it's
that same they want what for a used car
but
as you move away from
one
set of financial values and operating in
one financial reality and you move into
another one
your intellect often goes before your
emotions almost always and then like
it's like later on so i have to look
down at the coffee bill and and go okay
this company did bring in 350 million
dollars so we can probably cover this
coffee bill
you know so shut up you little whining
boy yes but on the other hand i look at
that number and it just there's still
that it still activates those old
emotions and so that tells me that still
today my emotions have not caught up
with
the intellectual activities required to
run a 350 million dollar company and it
may never it may
every time they do the company grows so
i can't keep up
that's right that's right i can't keep
the same thing with me you know sharon
and i were looking at buying something
last night and she goes i want to get
this and i'm going to spend a lot of
money and she told me how much it was
and i went that is not a lot of money
you little goob buy it but yeah that
nine-year-old little girl for me is
still like well that one the one that
was terrified and didn't think we'd ever
be able to fill up her grocery basket
again in the grocery store yeah and now
can and not think about it but she's
like that's a lot of nanny she's like a
mischievous like she's doing something
wrong i'm like honey puts two to zeros
on it and we'll call it a lot of money
i think dave that is so wise that
whether it's your marriage whether it's
your kids whether it's
you're in a career
to always just pause
have some built-in pauses
to go
here's a conversation we were having
upstairs we're working on this new book
we're we know we we say here if you're
not growing you're dying and i asked the
team it just hit me like a lightning
bolt what does growing mean to you what
does growing mean to you and they were
saying you know intellectual stimulation
and exercise plan a good morning routine
and reading and spiritual growth and all
these things
and david occurred to me in this
conversation this is just yesterday by
the way so i'm still processing it but
when you go lift weights
you're actually tearing your muscles
down it's when you rest that the growth
happens and so it's both and right it's
it's crushing it and reflection and so
it's gazelle intense and
i'm in a new stage here you are busting
the lactic acid man yeah i'm in a new
stage in a new stage and a new stage and
there's the pruning that causes growth
yeah and man it's always a breakdown to
build up always and when you it's when
you read that hard book or that hard
class it's at night when you sleep
that's when the neurons grow that's when
the growth happens right and so it goes
back to it's both and maybe i should
sleep more
i'll always tell you that yes
but
i love this gazelle
and hey don't forget to be reflective
and realize hey you're safe now you're
safe now
and now we're gonna start working about
giving and building and it's it's just
keep letting you make sure your head and
your heart stay connected through this
whole process man yeah that that's um
so jack all of that rant to say that um
for everybody else out there listening
what you're going through is normal yeah
it's a it's a normal part of the process
for your emotions to catch up with your
intellect take the whole 20 000 down to
1000 work the baby steps like you heard
when you were binging
and let's get that car paid off and get
that debt out of your life and the good
news is
you can look back when you're 54 and go
you know one of the dumbest things i
ever did was back when i was 24. i
bought a 50 000 car when i was 24 and
you can look back at this you know you
may have gotten the dumbest thing out of
the way
kathy is with us in grand rapids
michigan hi kathy how are you
i'm good how are you dave better than i
deserve what's up
um so
i have been through financial peace
university a couple times um i've
snowballed myself down to
mortgage payment and student loan
payment student loans will be paid off
for public loan forgiveness in about two
years
my mortgage payment is a 3.1 per 25
interest i have about 80 000 left on
that
um had to get a different vehicle
and this is kind of where the question
starts coming in so
just because of timing and how it worked
out and being out of town and no cars
available
i had intended to use some of
forty five thousand dollars i had saved
to get a new vehicle
i didn't know how i was going to piece
it together but long story short what i
ended up with
was um an auto loan of about 41 000 at
3.99
interest and that was by mistake i know
i can get a better rate than that so i'm
trying to get in to
refinance that auto loan but then my
questions come in is that really like
what should i do with this 45 000 i have
saved i i'm 55 i only have 25 000 in
mutual funds for retirement
what is your household income
um well that just jumped so it was at 56
000 and then in august it went up to
104.
okay
so i guess you're gonna have to go back
through financial peace university you
flunked
i did with that car thing horribly yeah
you did
and then you just called and asked me
how to refinance a car debt and keep the
car debt while you have the money in the
bank to pay it off
you just did that my
like what real like i really want to
know what's the best thing to do like i
do have the money you know what the best
thing to do is you went through the
class twice
but then i have nothing like i don't
because you bought a car you can't
afford left
yeah okay yeah yeah that's one of the
things i've been wondering is if i just
need well here's the thing if you if you
use your 45 000 to become debt free
other than your student loan
which is another problem by the way did
you know that two percent of the public
student loan forgiveness people actually
get it forgiven 98 of not
yeah no i didn't know that so i don't
have a lot of hope for your plan
um how much student loan debt have you
got
um there's 69 000 left okay
all right
so they did recently check out you can
do what you want to do and obviously you
regularly do that
um so here's what i would tell you to do
okay and this is going to be very
consistent with everything that i taught
you in that class okay okay we're going
to walk the baby steps
you have a hundred thousand dollars in
debt
40 of it is a car
69 is a student loan and you have forty
five thousand dollars in the bank you
have a car you can't afford you need to
sell your car
you need to take ten thousand dollars of
the forty five thousand and go buy you a
ten thousand dollar car
and then you need to use the rest of the
money and pay it on a student loan and
then you need to get on a debt snowball
beans and rice rice and beans on a debt
on a budget where you don't have any
life until you get that student loan
paid off because the federal private
student loan forgiveness program is an
absolute scam i just gave you the real
numbers
98
are not forgiven
two percent have that equals a lot of
people who bet on the government keeping
their word and they were lied to and
you're one of them if i woke up in your
shoes i would treat that student loan
like it was a cancer and i would pay it
off really really fast i'll get rid of
the car and undo the mistake that i made
there
probably got to write a check to do that
got to help you a little stupid tax
check there
and then
you move on from there now you get that
student loan paid off then you build
your emergency fund of three to six
months of expenses and then you start
investing fifteen percent of your
household income which in your case will
be fifteen thousand dollars a year
sixteen thousand dollars a year until
you get your home paid off you're going
to do all of this by the time you're 60
and and then you're probably going to
have your house paid off shortly after
that if you'll stay
on a plan
and quit losing your mind and driving
the car in the ditch no pun intended
so um but this is what people do and we
all do it we all make mistakes you made
a mistake now you've got a choice are
you gonna are you gonna double down
i'm gonna keep that car well you can you
keep the car that's fine
it's your decision you're like a grown
woman and stuff
so but you call me and made the mistake
of asking me what i would do and then i
am duty-bound to tell you
again
what i would do
jalen starts off this hour in atlanta
georgia hi jalen what's up
hi sir thank you so much for taking my
call sure how can we help
yes sir so i just actually learned about
uh the baby steps and all that you've
done starting in january but in december
i made the stupid maybe smart decision
uh i ordered a tesla model y and
learning that it's sixty thousand
dollars and that would put me in debt i
turned around as like okay that may not
be the best idea but then i came up with
uh ideas doing research that i could
generate it into passive income by
renting on suro and allowing others to
you know drive do as a rental property
essentially for the vehicle and make
that income back and paying off the debt
with that however i'd still be risking
having that debt because if things
happen and i'm not able to rent the car
out and things like that i could still
be withheld on paying almost a 900
monthly car note so i just wanted to
know if that's a good idea i'm 23 i'm
single i don't have any other debt
except for my current car which is my
kso but it's currently on positive
equity and i'm just continuing paying
that off learning from the baby steps so
just really want some advice with this
all right there's a lot going on here
jalen but i'm glad you found us is it
interesting dave they always find you
right after they do a dumb thing and
then a month later they go and i found
dave
it's amazing but let me answer let me
answer your question so you've got dead
on the key of soul and you're going i
got a business making opportunity by
getting a sweet toy and letting someone
else destroy it while i slowly painfully
pay back the debt on two cars now that's
a different way than he said it george
you're right that's the way i heard it
i'll say that jalen so no
do not get this tesla you need to pay
off this kia soul and if you do ever get
a tesla i want you to do it with cash
how much money do you make
so i just got a promotion actually in
january as well so i'm currently going
to be at 50 000 plus incentives you said
sixty thousand
yes so you're going to own a sixty
thousand dollar car making sixty
thousand dollars a year
when you put it that way it sounds even
worse okay that's why he did that that's
why he did it
and i want you to win financially and
the turo tesla deal is not going to be
the business model you you think yes so
jalen um here's the thing you really
good question and i really appreciate
you calling sir
um a good way to make some of these
decisions
is to uh pan way back
and say okay when i'm 35
12 years from now
which will be the best decision
and it kind of instantly leads you to
not doing the tesla thing and getting
the car paid off and starting to build
some wealth doesn't it
right but
the tesla only sounds good when you
think about taking delivery on it it
doesn't sound good when you're 35 you
have a 35 you have 12 year old battery
at that point with some wheels
right right and with my current car now
since i can get more than what it's
worth paying off the
the loan should i
what is the balance of the car that i
have what's the balance so iowa fourteen
thousand cars numbers offering the 17.
i'll just pay it off just just work
yourself you got a job just work work
your way out of it and then if you want
to trade cars do it with cash later but
let's just you have a small car debt
making fifty thousand
sixty thousand and let's turn around and
get it paid off as quick as we can
because again so the other thing i
always ask myself is what
and i went broke when i was 28
lost everything because i was stupid
so one of the things i started doing at
that point i started talking to old rich
people
i didn't want to talk to young rich
people i had been him he was stupid i
wanted to talk to old people who had
money made it and kept it
okay
and and then i've continued that for the
last 30 years that discussion with old
rich people to the point we did a
detailed in-depth research of the
largest research
study ever done on millionaires in north
america
and the number of millionaires out of
the 10 000 millionaires that we studied
the number of of them that said they
became a millionaire because they went
in debt to buy their car so they could
rent it out was precisely zero
none of them used your plan that you
presented to us a while ago
and so
you know and and because it's it's it's
just fraught with disaster there's so
many things that can go wrong in that
plan
that you laid out there
and um
you know if you've ever had a rental
property or ever put a property out as
an airbnb
you would know not to put your car out
in that system because people just don't
take care of it
people are gross as a matter of fact
they're just gross they're filthy
animals
and so you really find that out about
them when they live in stuff or will
drive stuff that you own
and it's just you're gonna discover that
with your sixty thousand dollar car with
your sixty thousand dollar income so
please don't do it i think you're not
going to i think we talked you out of it
but just for the other people listening
that are thinking in the same way i
wanted to make sure we drive the stake
deeply into the ground on that same yeah
pan back
ask yourself what would old rich people
do
because that's what you want to be
rich
when you're old
and dave when it comes to spending
decisions i like to think of it through
a framework where i go okay is this let
me have some self-awareness is this
going to add value to my life is it born
out of my values and i move on to
motivation and this is where it gets
really tough especially for young people
what's my motive do i have a good motive
in buying this thing am i trying to flex
on my friends do i want a shiny cool toy
so i feel successful and then i go into
affordability and i go can i afford this
in cash and if america answered that
correctly no one would be in debt would
they um then you go into research mode
and go is this the best price retailer
option that i can get and then you go
into timing and you go all right is this
the right time to buy this what's the
opportunity cost could i wait a year
could i wait three years and when you do
that it actually spells smart which is
really cute uh but what it does it helps
you just take a pause
and think through a framework to go
is this the right decision for where i'm
at financially and if you answer no to
any of those here's what it means not
now we're not saying we never want you
to have nice stuff i want you to drive a
model y tesla one day jalen but i want
you to do it when you get your income up
you can pay cash for this thing it's a
small portion of your life in your world
and you're not doing it to flex on other
people and you've done it because you're
already out of debt and you're investing
that that changes the game
you know i
very few
there's so many people we're a car
culture
uh and cars until the last 18 months go
down in value and they will again as
soon as this little supply demand curve
thing quits
they will depreciate again
and so it's the largest thing we buy
that goes down in value and once you've
gotten past transportation to take your
family somewhere or to take yourself to
work once you've gotten past that the
car is no longer a need everything above
basic transportation is a want and sadly
in my life when i was young
before i was 30 years old
it was we didn't call it flexing but
it's just trying to impress other people
trying to keep up with the joneses
trying to make somebody think i bought a
jaguar them so that people think i was
successful yeah based on the car you
drive
that's your measure but that's what
people do and i was that shallow i was
that dumb
jalen's not that dumb no
john is with us to start off this hour
in tulsa oklahoma hi john welcome to the
ramsey show
hey dave thanks for having me sure
what's up good
good to talk to you today um
we
i'm in a bit of a mess i
moved for i moved from uh
texas in
january
and uh of 2021 this year and this the
first time we've moved out away from
from everyone
um first time we had left the city that
we we
spent our whole lives in
and so we took a big leap of faith and
got out here to tulsa and um
it was just really
really kind of gotten ourselves in a
bind
i was i was listening to you hard and
heavy for about three months straight
before we
before we moved and we had big big plans
to
sit down and talk through some things
and figure some stuff out and we didn't
and i made a lot of dumb decisions since
then
and we are in all kinds of debt
we've got from credit cards to loans to
student loans car payments
um can we're just in over our heads so
so deep that we're trying to figure out
what to do you know
[Music]
so if you were completely free would you
move back home
i don't think so
okay
so what is the
was just the stress of being away from
what was uh familiar you think that
added to the bad decisions is that why
you're telling us about that part of it
yes definitely i do believe so there was
there's a lot of uh with my wife and i
we
we we let we we pastored for several
years
and
for five years and and
so we were out of
ministry for one year and we
we fully believe god spoke to us to move
to tulsa
[Music]
did you did you take another pastor
right there
no i did not um i'm also a plumber i've
i've i'm a i've got a master license in
texas i have a business there still that
generates a little bit of money
and i've worked for a plumbing company
here in this area
um
my wife is not working right now but
she's she's about to go back to work and
so that's going to help us a lot i know
what do you make now
probably about i make about 78 with with
one the one company it's probably close
to 100 combined and what does she what
will she make
um we'll probably be in the hundred i
would say 100 to 120 range together
combined all right i'm going to call it
120 because you told me 100 before you
said she went back to work all right so
um now
how much
is your house payment
14.50 a month okay and what do you owe
on the cars
um each
now okay 42 000
on one
and i took out a loan a person a couple
of personal loans and one of them is
tied to my truck now and so that one
that holds about 12 000.
okay
and you already had student loans before
you moved
yes and how much are the the student
the student loans they equal about sixty
thousand
did you say each
uh they're about they total about they
total about 60. okay so 42 12 and 60.
what other debts
um oh credit cards more loans
uh credit cards are probably about 8
000.
somewhere in there maybe a little less
loans are around 20 000.
just personal loans
yes okay so how much of this did you do
since you moved
um the the student loans in one car were
previous the big car that was all
previous
about half of the credit cards were
previous the new loans and credit card
debt is since we made
okay
so how can i best help you
we're i just i don't even know what
we're just such at such a loss right now
and and
there was a lot of bad decisions like i
said that that combined us together
making dumb dumb things and
we finally got back to church um we just
i'm wondering if there's like a group
here in tulsa that we can
find that that is a ramsay group is
there a way to find that sure we'll just
put you into uh ramsey plus into um you
know financial peace university and
there's a lot of churches teaching that
live and you can plug into that i'll pay
for that help you get started
um
okay
your language covers
the words you're using and the way
you're using them covers a lot of other
mistakes that aren't financial it sounds
like
yeah there there has been okay there's
been some different okay let's just
leave that there because
the weight of this doesn't the weight of
this in your voice doesn't really match
your numbers
that's why i was asking so um so what if
i said uh okay we're gonna get really
together uh you and your wife are gonna
work tight together you're gonna be on
beans and rice rice and beans you're not
gonna see the inside of a restaurant
unless you work there and you're not
going on vacation and you're selling her
stupid butt 42 000 car what if i said
that
that that's i we're we're on board we're
we're ready we we're both ready but
we've just been talking about it and
we're ready to do it now yeah you got to
start doing some stuff that's going to
hurt
yeah there's some pain involved in
living like no one else so that later
you can live and give
like no one else
and we're ready
yeah we just need some help to get
started i believe okay you know you want
to sell a bunch of crap and you're going
to cut your lifestyle to nothing
yeah you've been you've been eating
candy so much you've got a stomach ache
what amounts to
yes
like i take one of my grandkids to the
ice cream store and let them just you
know completely founder themselves and
then they're on a sugar high and their
belly hurts right
yes
and i you know what i john i'm i'm just
going to say this i'm not going to make
you respond to it but i think it's time
for you and your wife to forgive
yourselves
there's some shame there's some pain
that's driving some of these decisions
at some point you're going to have to
say god still loves us we still have a
lot of value to ourselves to our family
to our friends to him
allison's with us in tampa florida hey
allison what's up
hi
pleasure to be speaking with you today
um i'm calling because
i think i made the worst financial
decision of my life
oh what'd you do
i'm trying to get out of my timeshare oh
you did oh you made a horrible decision
i know
it's legalized fraud
oh
where did you buy a time share
like what state yeah or what company
where
i bought it in california in california
what company
it's wealth financial
oh my gosh okay
oh how long ago did you buy it
um 21.
wow just had a weak moment huh
yeah and you know my fiance and i are
just now trying to stay for our first
home so it's really just like
you still owe money on this thing
oh yeah are you kidding me oh yeah no
i'm not kidding and i've i've really
tried i tried everything contacting them
they have reiterated to me many times
they have no deep buyback programs and i
cannot sell or transfer the loan to
anyone until the loan is fully paid off
that's true yeah
oh
what it's a horrible horrible industry
it's just the worst like i got the two
calls back to back i got a whole life i
got a whole life call and that that the
next call has to be about payday lenders
i mean this is like the whole life to
timeshare to payday lenders we're gonna
have to get his blood pressure machine
oh man i'm so sorry i'm healthy yeah
you're just
how much do you owe on the stinking
thing
uh about 14k oh my gosh so what'd you do
go out there and stay like for free and
they put you in a room and wouldn't let
you out to your boat or how'd that work
um no we were at an amusement park and
they you know offered us a free vacation
which we got whether or not we wanted to
buy and i told him like my boyfriend at
the time
let's you know we're not gonna do
anything um the guy obviously like was
very good at his job um he had made a
lot of promises that i'm realizing
aren't even true like for example
if you book with one of their
part
excuse me partners then you get a free
week every time you book with them so we
went ahead and booked
um december the end of september come to
realize now we don't get that free week
because they're not with that company
anymore you know things like that oh so
this is called a fraudulent inducement
yeah he he told you a lie to get you to
buy
so uh here's what you do and i i don't
know if this will work but it's the only
shot you got okay
getting out of these things is very
difficult you stepped into a bear trap
and it got you on the leg and getting
out of it by yourself it's hard it's
very hard and even with help getting out
of it's very hard um
we man it's it's it's a nasty filthy
business as you've already discovered
yeah and i have heard of the timeshare
exit team they're gone i don't know they
got run out they got run out of business
by the by
the washington attorney general and by
the way
yeah they're horrible i mean it was a
horrible mess they got they did a good
job they got 20 000 people out but they
got run out of business by the time
share business
they uh legal bills they got sued 60 000
different ways and then they got the
timeshare business got the washington
attorney general after them and it was
just a disaster but for a while that was
a good avenue there is a couple of
groups that are still open doing exits
that are legitimate groups
they're legitimate companies that do
exits but the exit even using one of
these people is very difficult okay so
no guarantees but and they're not it's
not an endorsement i they don't work for
me they don't
you know they don't pay me or anything
like that there's a company called the
newton group
uh and they've actually been helping
some of the timeshare exit customers
that didn't get help because time share
went out of business
they're trying to help some of them too
but the newton group
at timesharetruth.com
and uh they've been here to our offices
we've met with them i met with mr newton
and with the several of the lawyers on
his staff they're good people
but they will look at you in the face
and say getting out of these things is
very difficult but sometimes they're
able to pull it off
but no promises but that's what i tell
you timesharetruth.com
the newton group
that that's the best thing i can give
you and other than that just yell at the
entire world don't ever
go to a timeshare presentation under any
circumstances there's no reason there's
no free vacation that's worth putting up
with this crap these are low-class human
beings it's a low-class business it's
nasty it's filthy they lie it's
legalized fraud have i been unclear ken
well dave i was going to ask you to
expound on that thought a little bit i
don't think you've covered it from
enough angles quite frankly but i don't
want to criticize hate the timeshare
business yeah because they screw people
and i just can't stand when the consumer
is getting messed over it makes me mad
so what if she can't get out of this
she's going to write a check she has to
pay 14 000 and then she's the proud
owner and then the stupid maintenance
fees are gonna go up every year right
and then can she sell it it's like it's
like it's like a disease you can't get
rid of oh that's unfortunate
you can't you they're for sale on ebay
for a dollar ooh nobody wants them
because you get the ma you get the
maintenance fees and the maintenance
fees go up every year
because these companies are just they're
just straight up scum
it's just awful
i mean they all of them are engaged in
it it's just oh just
uh please please people
you know it's don't never never go into
the tiger cage
that's what i call when you go in for
the sales presentation yeah oh it's like
the tiger has not been fed in four days
yeah but if you can sit in the tiger
cage and not get eaten for two hours
we'll give you a free disney vacation
yeah you know we'll let you go to the
water park for free if you can sit with
the tiger and not get eaten and he's
very hungry though we will tell you and
you sit in there with the tiger don't go
in the tiger they're going to win don't
go in they beat you down what do you
think you are tiger king stay out of
there man it's just don't do it stay
away from the tiger
stinking i'll eat you man it's
unbelievable we should do a hidden
camera thing where we put hidden camera
on me and let me be the most obnoxious
question ask her every time they put
some i throw a question back and we just
you could do that i could do it it would
be hysterical yeah you're be a big hit
dave i go in totally miked up you hidden
camera and i'll actually be the best
ramsey personality at being obnoxious i
drive
thank you dave that means a lot that's
like the line from chris's vacation
where wherever he says can you see all
right do you send george camo in there
no no it's me are you saying deloney in
there no he would already be
psychoanalyzing he would afford to get
out and
and rachel would make everybody their
friend i mean you would you or me we're
the only two that are left we have the
spiritual gift of confrontation that's
it well no we just stir up crap that's
what oh that's what i mean same thing
and so just just bugging them and
driving them nuts to watch the guy need
an antacid
by the time i'm done with him yeah you
know just like totally because here's
what they do what they do is it's high
pressure and they make you feel guilty
don't you're taking their freebie don't
you love your family yeah right you
don't love your family well
apparently as much as you do don't you
love your phone i would thrive in that
environment
i would love that it would be so good to
expose the high pressure as the
investigative reporter yeah right
oh i may do that oh i don't know there's
a couple of these guys that i owe on one
or two right now i own a couple of licks
back there's a i've bloodied their noses
a bunch of times but i'm not done yet
you're not
off the top ropes i hate those little
jimmy superfly snooker from the welding
just take david it's a body slam cause
you know who it is they take advantage
of that you know they take advantage
it's old people most of the time a lot
the vast majority of people get screwed
with time shares are the elderly they
load them up from nursing homes put them
on buses and take them to presentations
oh yeah but they also prey on people who
actually are broke and what they do is
they put a twinkle in their eye and they
make them feel like they can experience
what the better half is is living
the other half i'm telling you it is an
absolute uh manipulation too for folks
like i wonder what the poor people are
doing it's like hey for a really good
price you can live like everyone else
yeah you see what's going on there right
yeah it's fomo yeah yeah that yeah for
sure oh my gosh yeah and if you loved
your family
you'd spend time with them on vacation
we don't guilt trip here but i just want
you to know are you i just want to know
are you a good father
i just want to know do you love it you
want to go do you really think that
works do you love yourself simple-minded
do you think i am that's awful women you
don't love your children
no you look like a man that loves his
children
i mean you get to buy a time share to
prove it
dale is in boise hi dale welcome to the
ramsay show
yeah thank you for having me on sure
what's up
um so i got a question for you i mean we
pretty much have solid you know all the
baby steps
owned several pieces of property free
and clear pretty much dumped all our
money into
paying everything off
um but here later in life we decided to
build a rv park because it seems to be
kind of a trend
and
we have an sba loan but
we can't pay the loan off as fast as we
would like to because there's a really
hefty
repayment penalty so it's like well what
do we do
you know with the extra money that that
we can't
you know run like we usually do
you know keep keeping it you know
everything paid off low profile i mean
we've had the same cars that we've had
for 25 years we don't just go what's the
balance on the sba loan
uh 1.8 million
ouch
and it has a prepayment penalty on a two
million dollar loan
that's really unusual okay
10 years it's uh
2.38 interest
fixed for 20-year amortization but we
can't pay it off for ten
ten years
and uh
how many years on the ten how long ago
would you do this math
we just it we just flipped from the
construction
takeout to the permanent finance team
good lord
have you done the math on the difference
between the prepayment penalty and the
interest you would save by paying it off
early
it's um 25
of the loan
so it's substantial
you know you're looking at you know 425
thousand dollar prepayment totally
at what point in the process did you not
stop and go this is a dumb butt idea
well the the the cash flow makes it
worthwhile
of doing but hypothetically
unless nobody comes to an rv park
because there's a pandemic and then you
go bankrupt
and you took out a prepayment penalty of
25
and willingly knowingly signed up for
that
wow dude government
at its finest i mean that's what no no
no
the government didn't have a gun to your
head you signed the paper the the lender
can make up whatever wacko terms they
want to you have you have feet to walk
away then you're supposed to use them
man oh my god all right so do you have
any money
uh very little cash on hand right now
most of all of our uh xbas money has
went into the construction because the
prices of everything have went up 200 to
300 percent hold on hold on it's not
hold on it's not because of the prices
it's because you chose to spend it
yeah
your whole orientation is everybody did
this to you yeah
like it was out of your control you know
like you didn't have a choice to do all
this so all right you've done it now i'm
gonna quit beating on you so here's the
deal
uh what you've got to do is you need to
save up 1.8 million dollars as fast as
you can and set it in an investment to
the side
so that when the 10-year clock goes
ding-ding you write a check
and um you need you need a tremendous
amount of liquidity no you don't need to
pour anything else into this
freaking rv park
no
uh you're already deep in it so what you
need to do is take any money you can
find from anywhere and begin an
investment pool on the side to pay this
loan off the day it hits
the um
[Music]
the the date gets down small enough that
you can that you want to bite the bullet
on the prepayment penalty or the day it
hits the 10-year mark and you write that
check so you need a mutual fund that the
target on it is i want to put 1.8
million dollars in
and you better hope that gas doesn't get
up to four dollars and 50 cents a bear i
mean a gallon again people quit
taking their rvs out as much as they
have the last few years yeah yeah again
dang man that's heartbreaking you're
going to be stuck in your old cars for a
season man you put yourself in big
trades interest rates go up you know
what happens to rv sales
i stop and when gas prices go up people
quit toting around the country and same
man
yeah
i'm just a barrel we're just barely good
news today but um i tell you anyway but
yeah that's something good happened to
you call today too yeah
oh so yeah the answer to your question
is no you don't put money back into the
business yes you pile money on the side
as fast as you can politics as you can
pilot so you've got liquidity because
you have a bigger mess on your hands
than you perceive
and that's why we're both kind of we
have both have both of us john and i
have a little panic in our voice that
you are not experiencing in your body
and when that does hit your body someday
i want you to have a big pile of money
because it's coming yeah it's um take
ownership of your choices brother
hey if you enjoyed this episode click
here to watch the next one which is all
about some career nightmares